it wasn't just a close contact coven 19
situation for cupp it's a positive he
won't be available at
all andrew whitworth left tackle he's
been designated to return from into
reserve but not expected to play on
sunday so no
whitworth cam akers ankle injury didn't
practice on wednesday he missed the week
16 game i think one of the reasons why
they lost to the seahawks frankly
malcolm brown limited with a shoulder
injury daryl henderson on injured
reserve
holy crap they have to bring back eric
dickerson
chris how can they win with
these many guys missing offensively i
gotta think that they're they're
they're thinking cam akers is going to
be able to play the football game you
know
they do have two rookies on the roster
that of course could
could run the football a little bit but
i just feel like
if if they didn't feel like cam akers
was going to play i don't know would we
hear about them trying to sign a running
back
do something like that here for the last
football game
you know the last game of the year to
get in the playoffs and all that so
just between mcvay's comments and things
you hear out there
i think they're hopeful there but man
yeah they are a beat up football team on
the offensive side of the ball
and in a week where you know again you
don't want to you want to make things
easy
on your backup quarterback no cooper cup
i mean cooper cup yeah he's a wide
receiver
but he catches all his passes you know
right in the five and six yard range
he's huge on the bootlegs hey he fakes
the block down then he sneaks out into
the flat or he
sneaks behind the line of scrimmage and
catches the ball in the flat off the
bootleg
very important let alone we know the run
game is always important for a young
quarterback too so that's where it's
you know a little concerning and you
know they had their way
with with the cardinals a little bit in
the run game in some ways to where the
cardinals got so worried about it the
first time around they over
played it and people in the box and that
made the bootleg game and things
wide open for jared goff so gonna be an
interesting matchup but man the rams are
beat up
the other options at tailback are xavier
jones right and
raymond kellease who i it's spelled the
same as caleas campbell so i presume
it's pronounced the same as coleas
campbell i don't know because
yeah either has played in the regular
season ever
and it could be those guys thrust into
action and look even if you get these
guys ready
the main guys if acres can play if brown
can play
you put them out into the ultimate car
crash position in football
they may not make it very long once they
start getting hit so these other guys
had better be ready and my guess is
they'll have jones
and kaleas on the active roster and in
uniform
on sunday ready to go and at a minimum
put them on special teams
and use them that way and then have them
prepared in the event that acres and
brown if both
are in uniform get banged up when it's
time to go out there and play chris
yeah no and well that's got to be
worrisome for mcveigh these are you know
these two running backs that you just
mentioned there i mean one's kind of
like a
third down jitterbug type back so he's
not going to be your bell cow
and yeah all these two have done is
played special teams
so in an offense where there are checks
at the line of scrimmage and little
rules you got to know about you know
what to do and all that i'm sure mcveigh
doesn't
you know they're not in the trust tree
those type of football players
and that's probably where it's a little
bit concerning for for a sean mcvay but
uh i i think we're going to end up
seeing the cam acres just by what we
were
what we were told there i don't know
what the status of malcolm brown will be
um but the the they're going to be
fighting an uphill bottle on the
offensive side of the ball they're going
to have to play a smart
hope their defense can shut down the
cardinals which they did the first time
around
you know it'll look like oh hey that
game was you know more than
what we thought the rams defense
dominated the cardinals the first time
around
the cardinals got a touchdown on the
first drive by a blown coverage
by the rams and then other than that
they didn't have a real
legit drive other than one time the rest
of the game
they scored a touchdown off a muff punt
um from
from the los angeles rams in a short
field that way
they really struggled and this rams they
got the number one defense in football
they're going to have to rely on them
this week to be dominant i think for
them to win the football game
making the job easier for the rams
defense the fact that kyler murray
is banged up you saw him play through a
shoulder injury although he wasn't
as effective as he'd been before the
shoulder injury now he's got some sort
of a lower leg
injury ankle injury whatever fully
participated in practice
on wednesday it's and and it was
identified as
how do you identify this i got to look
at the injury report leg is what we have
in here
usually it's more specific than that
regardless here's kyler murray talking
about his desire
and intention to play when sunday rolls
around
go tweet out that i'm going to play yeah
i'll be playing
there's no um you know holding back uh
we lose i'll be home chilling so i mean
it's my leg you know i'm fine
you know it's an opportunity that uh you
know only we could ask for
is a you know opportunity to play in the
playoffs get in
and where we want to be obviously with
everything that's happened this year
and yeah we still got opportunities so i
think everybody should embrace it
and leave it out on the field on sunday
and there it is i'm looking at the
injury report all it is is leg
no more specificity than leg although it
is
lower leg we know it's lower leg uh
because that's what cliff kingsbury said
earlier this week not him it's chris
strebler
and without kyler murray it's likely
done
i'm i'm intrigued by what stravaler can
do
yeah right but i don't think he can beat
the rams
uh given that that defense aaron i'm
it's one it's one thing to play in the
cfl and he wasn't a full-time
quarterback he did a lot of different
things he was an injury replacement he
had
12 touchdowns rushing the ball in 2019.
he's a runner
but but and it's it's weird i watched
some of his cfl highlights
he runs with kind of a like a little
engine that could
strike yeah i know there's a little
watch right he doesn't open it up it's
it's short choppy steps and there
it's a he looking hill if that makes any
sense
to me you know it is it is and i don't
know that it's going to fly in the nfl
you know you can see certain styles
at lower levels of football and it works
like he'll get the snap there was a play
down near the goal line where he got the
snap
and he just kind of he kind of ran into
the bodies
like an electric football player would
you know how when you have
the the the quarterback or the guy
that's got the ball and it's just they
all
push right and he just kind of follows
that's what it looked like it just
looked ungainly and awkward
and i don't think that's gonna make it
in the nfl maybe it will
but unless he's ch it just doesn't look
right i
i hope i'm articulating that right
really doesn't look right
he doesn't look like an nfl guy when you
see his highlights from the cfl no it is
more
run based you know it doesn't like wow
you with the throwing
and that's where i mean it could be
interesting maybe they have a totally
different approach with him as the
quarterback
i mean obviously they think he can run
the offense and do that stuff
but maybe they like the legs and that
aspect that he can bring to
maybe it be a little bit of a change up
that way but
i don't think there's any way kyla
murray misses this football game i mean
he just let us know right there as
interesting as the straddler situation
is
i want to see kyla murray out there
anyways i do and you know arizona
you know again yeah i mean they need
kylo ren they're too kyler murray
centric
he hasn't been playing that great lately
i mean their offense got dominated last
week in that football game they got
dominated
you know can't throw make any plays for
any yards
run game not that special other than
kyla murray just ripping off
a few plays here and there but they
can't just line up and say here kenny on
drake
we're gonna overpower you guys in the
run game and impose our will on you
and no they can't do any of that so
they're concerning
uh that way and that's where i just look
at it and i don't care if it's what you
know john wolford or jared goff or
whatever
i just have a hard time thinking that
arizona can beat the rams this week i
really do
i feel like arizona's gonna end up being
the odd man out in the nfc
and it's a shame because i think they
could be very exciting in the postseason
yeah but for as good as the bills have
been since hail murray
the cardinals have not been very good at
all that was the peak to their season
the problem is they don't give you a
trophy for that you got lifetime
memories
you got highlights that play on an
endless loop you've got one of the best
images of the season
but when you don't follow it up with
winning football it's all for naught
alex smith washington football team
quarterback the odds-on favorite by far
i don't even think they have any other
options on the board at this point to be
comeback player of the year
will he come back from a calf injury and
play this weekend here he is from
wednesday explaining how close he came
to playing
in week 16 against the carolina panthers
hey alex how close were you to being
able to go last week
yeah i mean close i mean i felt really
close certainly
i got a lot in on friday and you know
and that was my mindset
all week really close though i mean it's
like i guess it's hard to say other than
that certainly
right on the doorstep of it
officially no practice on friday for
alex smith he was working off to the
side taylor heineke had the first team
reps on the major work day in advance of
a sunday game
on wednesday so this is going to be a
wednesday what did i say you said friday
but it's all good i just want okay
friday wednesday be
the aba he was talking about friday so i
got into my brain wednesday right
because today's thursday
today's not saturday so it had to be
wednesday exactly because today's
thursday
so anyway no practice on wednesday for
alex smith taylor heineke
taking all the reps on wednesday the day
before today
but today is thursday which is my friday
today is thursday yeah it's my friday
well i know
but you know what this week it's my
everybody's friday oh the hell is it
that's not a good friday night because
it's new year's eve day
right you're you're jealous of the fact
that you're not the only one that gets
friday off this week
two bad sims anyway uh thursday and
friday will be the key days for alex
smith how much practice will he get in
will he be good to go
i just don't have a whole lot of faith
in taylor heinecke leading the
washington football team all due respect
in a win and in scenario because you
know the eagles
they're going to love the opportunity to
knock out their rivals i mean
eagles had that 17-point lead earlier
this year and they blew it and
jalen hurts is trying to cement his
standing and doug peterson would very
much like to come back and this would be
a great opportunity for them
to do it elsewhere in the division and
we'll know by the time
that washington at philadelphia kicks
off on sunday night football on nbc
whether or not it will be dallas or the
giants winning the nfc east in the event
that washington does lose
daniel jones working through a hamstring
injury that
we thought should have kept him on the
shelf a little bit longer than it has
here he is yesterday explaining the
limitations on his game as a result of
the lingering hamstring problem
you know i've played from the pocket um
you know the past
couple weeks and and you know i expect
to
you know continue to do that until i'm
until i'm uh healthy so
um you know we'll see uh
what exactly but um you know i expect
the the game plan and
and what i'm asked to do to be fairly
similar to what it's been
these past few weeks
kind of surprising given the entire joe
judge bill belichick don't say anything
shocking unless
unless it's a deliberate misdirection we
can't rule out the possibility i don't
know
that daniel jones daniel jones is the
straight guy that was put out there
to you know he's got nothing you can't
you can't read him right he's out there
and he's saying it and it's like is he
well yeah oh if he says it must be true
you know i'd buy
aluminum siding from daniel jones seems
like a nice guy doesn't seem like
someone who'd try to grift me
maybe he's drifting the dallas cowboys
by saying that the game plan's the same
as it's been the last couple of weeks i
i mean i thought
you know i that crossed my mind too when
i read it when i read it yesterday i was
just like man i can't believe he's
actually kind of saying this i just
i was a little surprised by that because
of like what you said joe judge why
why let the cowboys know like oh yeah
i'm not going to be able to keep the
ball on the read option you know and run
the ball down the sidelines or do any of
that why
why let them know that you know that's
been a big problem with their offense
that's been an issue you know the fact
that he can't run has really hurt the
rest of their offense altogether
you know his few runs every game it
helped their offense find a few ways to
get some chief
cheap explosive plays it helped out you
know wayne gallman and the rest of the
run game because you got to worry about
daniel jones that two or three times a
game he might rip off a 15 or 20 yard
run
and of course you know even though it
even is scrambling not that he's a great
scrambler
but he is a guy that when the red sea
parts and he tucks it
he can go you know they need that aspect
of the game or at least the
the fearfulness of that might be there
and he has not been all that impressive
without the movement
the last few weeks and i also feel like
you see it a little bit in this throwing
too to where it affects him so
uh i'm shocked to hear them say that i
really am i i
this is one i'm gonna put a pin in
because we're three days away from the
game
i'm gonna be curious to see if it really
is some sort of a setup some sort of a
ruse some sort of an
effort by daniel jones to get the
cowboys to think it will be the same as
what it's been
and then the next thing you know off he
goes running down the field untouched
before before he falls flat that was not
a carefully articulated answer to make
me think
it was planted in there before to have
something to say like
that so to just from reading him knowing
people
seeing that that looked like a total raw
real answer and he was just laying it
out there and
yes it's i don't think he should have
done that but either way he was honest
and i'm never too mad at anybody for
that
i agree with you that it does seem like
right
it is the real position that they're
taking
and the real game plan they're
instituting which makes it even more
impressive if it's not that's why i'm
curious to see
if all of a sudden come sunday it's
daniel jones running all over the place
because you're right i mean if
he saw that so well that uh i don't know
maybe he should head to hollywood or
somewhere because that that was that was
effective because a lot of times when
guys are
are feeding us a line of crap we can
just tell we can tell
because there are tells there are things
in their demeanor and he just
yeah he said it and it just came out and
uh maybe he had some explaining to do to
joe judge after that like daniel what
the hell are you doing why don't we just
give them
the playbook because while we're at it
well here here let's just show let's
just show them what our first 15 plays
are
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports